first of all you're so wonderful in this
but i do want to ask you about what you
had to go through to get you know
essentially this look the hair because i
know that's such an important aspect of
this character
how's your hair doing now
how's hair doing now it's grown back in
um i i had i had to bleach my hair every
10 days for the roll because she's a
she's a natural blonde
um and and so we couldn't have any black
roots coming in and you would see even
like a millimeter of root because my
hair is so dark and my hair was
important the film um and so
so we bleached it every 10 days and by
the end of the shoot i had hair falling
out like
big hunks of hair out of the front of my
head i was like if we don't wrap soon i
am truly going to look like i've just
had chemo my hair is literally falling
out
i was like it kind of works it works for
the character she did
you know so absolutely um what did your
kids think because obviously they can be
brutally honest
oh gosh my kids haven't seen this movie
no did they see your hair though while
you were in character were they like
trying to figure out if this is mom
okay so i shaved my head about a year
before i did this movie for myself
like this i just shaved my head it
wasn't for the role it was for me so i
actually had to grow my hair for this
movie believe it or not i spent two
months growing my hair for this movie
and then i bleached it my kids hate it
hated it and would tell me all the time
that i was ugly with my hair that way
and that i should grow back my pretty
hair and be pretty again
oh wow
we still do by the way
like rushing my oldest one i think he
has a very specific idea of how a woman
should look and it's natural
well you were showing them you can
obviously be just as beautiful with
short long doesn't matter i hope that
they grow up to be very open-minded
young men who are attracted to women of
all types and styles
i love that so much so um i want to ask
obviously about uh this film and and but
with jason sedakis were you
are you like everybody else have you
become obsessed with ted lasso
totally obsessed with ted lasso
first season i was obsessed with ted
lasso i was so emotional
i'm watching
i'm doing the old school tv thing and
watching every episode as it comes out
on fridays right now
which i love that they're doing
i actually think it's a way better way
to experience television so that you
have that forced week in between for the
stories to kind of just ruminate inside
of you so that by the time you get to
the next one you really take it in and
give it some time also i just binge
watched um the third season of sex
education the other day yes yeah i think
i did it over two days or i think it was
only two days i mean i watched the whole
season in like two evenings and i now
find myself going i have to go back and
re-watch that that was too fast because
it didn't sink in didn't sink in i feel
like i missed
half the beauty of it all so i love that
they're releasing it
one every week and sort of helping me
with my willpower because otherwise i
could just binge the whole thing and
allowing me to watch it week by week
it's true and i feel like it just gets
people more excited something to look
forward to i feel like people felt that
way with loss like the anticipation for
each episode after each mystery right
people missed that totally
totally and if you didn't have that week
to wait if you didn't have that water
cooler conversation the next day at work
about everybody being on in sync having
seen the same thing at the same time
and that creates this pop culture sort
of consciousness where where it's in the
zeitgeist but now the way things are
released if you watch it
and get completely obsessed with let's
say
let's say look at game of thrones yeah
you know there's a very good chance that
your neighbor or your friend or your
coworker is like oh yeah that's on my
list i'm going to watch it maybe in a
month or like next week but you're never
going to be synced up the way we used to
be when we would watch um serial
television together like
it's true it's absolutely true um did
you note the idea of this film did you
read the script what was it about this
this project that you really wanted to
be a part of
well first of all it was aaron cascellis
who is the director he's an israeli
director who did a film called big bad
wolves that was in my opinion a total
masterpiece and it was not my kind of
movie it was it was about
it was a thriller about pedophilia which
when i first watched the opening scene i
was like oh no no no no i can't i can't
stomach that kind of movie that's not
what i watch
but he had done it with such artistry it
was so visually beautiful and it was so
sensitive there's something about it
that i was like
maybe i could keep watching and maybe
i'll just keep watching until i can't
stomach it anymore and now i'll turn it
off just to see if i like this director
because i'd already read something
and i got all the way to the end of the
movie and i never turned it off
and i i was absolutely astounded that he
could take a topic as horrific as
pedophilia and
like not deal with a homicidal maniac
and treat it with such
sensitivity and sweetness and aesthetic
beauty and also with such incredible wit
and his like the timing of his dark
humor
that i could stomach it as somebody who
doesn't like violence and doesn't like
to watch violence so when i read this
script
to me it was too violent i was like this
is unnecessary it's way too violent i
don't i don't really like that but i
loved what he'd done with big bud roles
and i loved annie
and i really wanted to play annie and
she to me was an opportunity for me to
take the shackles off of always being
the tough
gas
leading lady and just be
soft and
full of love and light
and that is that was so refreshing for
me to be able to do and then of course
jason sedakis and i met and he was as
charming as can be
and um
yeah that's your uncle i want it in
yeah
um you know when you're dealing with uh
you know obviously sensitive issues on a
film like this and even though you know
you have those moments in there what was
the the tone like on set like does jason
sadek us bring the comedy were you guys
having is that like a release for you
guys in terms of what you're dealing
with with the script no
so i
this
no
so the script was actually quite
different from the tone that the film
ended up in the script was intended to
be a noir comedy
and
thinking i was getting like funny
jovial charming jason steakis yeah and
he came in with a completely different
take on jimmy ray and he had jimmy ray
pegged and in a way that was like very
dramatic and was doing it kind of a
different flavor than what i think
anybody expected him to bring
so
aaron cascelli's being an incredibly
collaborative director immediately
pivoted based on jason's performance and
then i was like
what am i doing
what am i doing like what what's this
now what are we doing and so we we just
everything kind of turned and what
became really strange
almost was that
my character became a kind of lightness
and his character became the heaviness
which is not is not what i was sort of
imagining when i when i signed on to do
the job but i think in the finished
product is kind of beautiful
absolutely no it definitely worked i
don't know if i would have known that
that originally it had been
the pivot it was a bit different at the
beginning yeah
like originally it wasn't that that
annie was really heavy
right but definitely the tone was like
sunny and bright and funny like dark
but for sure yeah
you know i can only imagine that you
know when you're dealing with a
character like this and
and just this story if you had one year
left on this earth and you wanted to do
absolutely anything what would be on
your bucket list
gosh i've asked myself that question
many times because i actually know
people who have been diagnosed with
terminal cancer yeah and
i i every time i come up with nothing
i'd sort of come to the place of like i
i certainly wouldn't act anymore
i think i would just spend my time with
my loved ones
but not only that i would just do so
much of the things that i already do all
the time like i love to walk in the
forest and i would do that a lot um i
love to pray
i know i would do that a lot i love to
read i would read a lot of books i don't
think much
would change
because i think i always have this sense
of like
not wanting to be chasing something ever
and i think especially if i knew that i
didn't have much time left i wouldn't
want to feel like i was chasing anything
i would just want to feel like i was
i was present in every moment
and i think that's really the heart of
annie also is
jason's character jimmy ray
is trying to somehow put the past behind
them and make up for lost time
and she has fully accepted and
integrated the past into who she is and
where she is and is like
i don't need to fix anything i just want
to be here with you
that's all i need i don't need anything
and he can't wrap his head around that
yeah because he's feeling the ticking
clock yeah
i love that well i think that's also a
true testament to how you're living your
life right now and that you're doing the
right thing
trying
i just got the rap but i do want to ask
about the ant-man sequel uh how much fun
do you have you know you shoot a film
you have this character you take time
apart and then you get back into the
character of hope how much fun is that
for you
well it's always a little bit
nerve-racking because
well yeah because for me it's always um
it's like i want to honor the character
and have her be
same
character that people come to know and
love
but in every story she goes through a
massive
emotional evolution and so i want to
also represent that shift or that change
and that can sometimes be really hard in
these big tentpole franchise films where
most of the time is dedicated to the
action
right like they're not character driven
i mean they are i mean marvel does a
good job of making them character driven
but they're like you know they're action
or focus films yeah so that's always a
little bit nerve-wracking for me i
always have this this insecure feeling
of like okay where is she now how do i
represent that what does that look like
what does that sound like and how do i
make sure that you can see all of that
she's the same person but that she's
evolved and changed and um i
unfortunately i put a lot of pressure on
myself probably unneeded pressure but
i'm a bad person
oh gosh i wish i could be like yay it's
gonna be so fun
every time but i'm like oh god billions
of people are gonna see this and i have
to do it right it has to be good and
um so yeah it's a bit of both
anything you can tease is about her
journey this time
no
[Laughter]
no absolutely nothing there's nothing i
can tease because i am already the
person who blows all the secrets all the
time
i love that
you